hello
and welcome we are now in live mode
join the webinar
you're starting in about a minute
actually gonna
stop the timer here
and
all right thank you very much uh see
we've got people rolling in
and
why don't everybody as you're joining
let us know where you're joining us from
can you tell us what the city state
if you're outside we have a Divine from
the Philippines welcome
simran from uh Canada
now we're very excited about this nagpur
lots of people coming in Cashmere
New Delhi haranya
Durban
lots of people from India
welcome everybody I hope you're doing
well this evening
and we're as you can see we're here with
Professor Sandeep Shukla of IIT confer
people from all over
India from Bangalore to Pune to
Kerala
so let's get started
and my name is Stuart Creek I am with
simply learn
we're the delivery partner with IIT
Concord for their program and
cyber security red team ethical hacking
and penetration testing
we're going to talk today with the
professor
Shukla about
careers
in cyber security
and
then we'll talk a little bit about this
particular program
before we get to this point yeah let me
ask you a poll question
this poll question to get a feel for
who's in our audience today is
how many years of experience do you have
are you currently studying for your
degree or are you in the workplace
you can put that into the poll
widget that you see on your screen
I'll leave this open for just another
five seconds
and we'll close the poll now
Professor you can see that our audience
today
is a little more than half of people who
are still studying for the degrees
then we have a range of experience in
the other half
so
I want to give you a little background
about what we're going to be doing today
as you can see we're going to be asking
questions about you and the audience
we'll do talking about cyber security as
a technology and then cyber security as
a career field career choice for you
um we'll talk a little bit about how the
program from IIT Contour can get you job
ready
in a specific aspect of cyber security
and also will cover enrollment steps and
a bonus offer that you receive being
here at this webinar and then professor
and I will take your questions
I want to do a short introduction of
Simply learn
simply learn as I said as a delivery
partner with IIT contour for this
program we're very proud of that they
chose us because we're the number one
online boot camp in the world and we've
helped
over 5 million professionals worldwide
upskill in digital skills it's our
specialty and we deliver our upskilling
programs completely online so they're
available to you wherever you are
uh whether you're in India or in any
other country in the world so we're um
extremely proud to be partnered with IIT
Khan poor and I'm going to let the
professor introduce himself because he
is a distinguished expert not only in
cyber security but blockchain and
National if not International leader
into those fields a welcome professor
uh good evening everybody and I am
Sandeep Shukla uh I am a professor of
computer science uh an engineering at
the Indian Institute of Technology
tanpur and I also uh coordinate the
interdisciplinary Center for cyber
security and cyber defense of critical
infrastructure which is uh more
popularly known as c3i Center and we I
also uh I'm also a program director for
uh CTA Hub which is a Technology
Innovation housing service security uh
hosted here in iot kanpur and also I am
a coordinator for the national
blockchain project which is also a
project by the funded by the national uh
Security Council Secretariat so uh I did
my uh Masters and PhD from State
University of New York and I taught at
Virginia Tech for about uh 13 years uh
before coming to India for uh joining uh
IIT kanpur back in 2015. So and my main
research and teaching is around cyber
security and blockchain Technology
thank you so much
and
that leads us into this discussion about
cyber security as a Technology field
um
so
we've experienced you know not just in
the last couple of decades as the
personal computer became ubiquitous and
as
we all started becoming interconnected
through the internet
but especially within the last several
years so much of our personal lives our
business lives have moved into the
digital domain how has that affected the
impact of cyber security on all of us
so uh so digitalization is uh the uh way
of life today so we do everything like
banking uh to uh Telecom to uh our power
grid our power system our water
treatment plants uh our oil and gas
pipeline uh and Industrial uh production
lines everything is computerized and
with uh computers communication Network
and various kinds of sensors and various
kinds of activities so as a result what
is happening is that the Cyber attackers
of various kinds are trying to attack
this kind of systems uh some are
actually how we hackers who are just
doing it for fun uh some are actually
activists who are doing it for uh
activism and then there are also cyber
criminals who are doing it for money and
then there are uh nation state attackers
they are the groups affiliated with
various countries like North Korea Iran
Russia China Etc who are actually doing
it for uh you know uh for uh putting a
particular country who they do not like
uh into trouble so these are the
situation that we are facing today uh
with respect to the the digitalization
that uh is uh done uh for uh better
um better service delivery better
production better performance but we
have this problem of cyber security
yeah and it
if you think about where a cyber
attacker could uh
hit you I mean there's
every place that the your network is
connected it's a potential entry point
right
yeah so I'm in uh you know start with
your handheld phone smartphones that you
uh actually uh download apps and so on
and you can be attacked there you could
be attacked at your laptop your desktop
uh your network devices like uh routers
and switches and firewalls uh you have
uh you know and servers uh on which
various important Services run so you
can have Cyber attack on any of these
devices which are part of the digital uh
ecosystem yeah and the attacks can take
the form of uh
trying to steal sensitive data that you
want protected or they can pick the form
of
uh interfering with the operations or
disabling the operations of uh
computerized systems they're or
sometimes both yeah
yeah so stealing data uh or
um holding you for ransom by encrypting
your data and and asking for payment uh
in cryptocurrency
is one common thing that we have seen a
lot uh wiper wiper attacks where they
wipe your discs and drives also stealing
attacks for data stealing or detox
filtration uh where they actually take
your data and sell it
on the on the dark web in the black
market uh then there are attacks on the
power system or water treatment plants
or oil and gas pipeline Etc to disrupt
the operation yeah there was a incident
several years ago in Germany where
uh cyber attackers attacked the hospital
and disabled its systems uh such that
they had to reschedule surgery is
another procedures they could proceed
with them so it's a an amazing
malicious world out there
um
this is something that
a few headlines taken out but I live
near Oakland California
and Oakland has been dealing with a
ransomware attack that's been going on
for a couple of years now
they haven't been able to resolve it
um you know this type of thing is
as you said common worldwide talked
about nation states
cyber attacks between Crane and Russia
going in both directions is
new domain or theater of war that the
countries have to deal with
um and then you know just overall it's
become a top of Mind priority for
Business Leaders yes
right yeah so uh I mean uh right now uh
so uh you cannot really plan for uh a
business continuity see normally people
used to think about business continuity
in terms of various exigencies that
might happen uh in the business like uh
you know certain uh shortage of supplies
or certain labor shortages or certain
skill shortages or money shortage and
Etc and they used to design design their
uh resilience of the organization or of
the business uh based on such uh
assumptions but now more and more people
are actually considering cyber security
threat as one of the exigences that they
have to plan for and that's where uh it
is becoming a high priority item in the
deliberation of the board of the
businesses as well as desktop Executives
they actually are
investing a lot they are actually
creating cyber security teams inside the
organization uh some organizations are
also getting services from cyber
security Consulting and and services so
cyber security is basically uh you
cannot avoid
thinking about cyber security and doing
something about cyber security in
today's world if you are running a
business yeah
and some interesting quotations from
from uh business and and government
leaders
the the
ciso of grouped Seb made a great
observation which is you can take
decades to build the reputation of a
company and one cyber incident can
completely destroy it
I've seen that in a number of places
haven't we
yeah so um I'm in the one of the major
thing that happens is uh uh there are uh
there were cases in the beginning of
this cyber uh you know era uh the credit
card uh the card companies uh that had
uh hacking and and data stealing uh they
got they got closed down because of the
reputational damage uh brand reputation
uh the business reputation uh customer
Goodwill these things uh go away if your
car if the data customers data that you
have been entrusted with uh leaks out
because of cyber attacks on your company
so it's very
um important to uh protect your
customers data uh in order to actually
uh guard the reputation of the company
that you have built uh over that uh long
number of years yeah and then the
the effort to repair it it's not just a
matter of repairing the uh the breach
and securing the systems and the data
again but it's also repairing your
reputation which can cost millions of
dollars in terms of uh public relations
and maybe even compensation to people
um the the former director of the FBI
uh made kind of a humorous comment
there's only two types of companies
those that have been hacked and those
that will be hacked so
um that's kind of fatalistic but it's
kind of accurate isn't it
yeah just uh there is another saying
that uh uh all companies have been
hacked uh I some know it and some don't
yeah that's a that's a important that's
an important thing and if you don't know
it the the damage that can be happening
in the background without your knowledge
is is incredible so
um
the the last quote here from uh the
founder of DPI is uh if our computer is
not safe we are not safe mentally and
socially and that
the way people interact Now with uh with
apps with their smartphones
with social media all of these digital
domain environments where people
put so much of their
um personal
uh investment of their their
self and their business and their
lifestyle
that's really
um
and their finances absolutely so if you
feel like you're not secure in those
things it really does create this kind
of um
mental social
doubt and insecurity and you you can
have that kind of uh breakdown of of
your your feeling of
uh safety
um so the the growth of the sector is
just amazing
um
we're looking at you know 173 billion
dollars U.S spending worldwide uh for
cyber security now but it's
likely to
grow by 50 or so over the next several
years at a compound rate of 10.5
almost 11 percent a year so this is uh
do you see any signs of that slowing or
is it still accelerating
no no uh so among other things that are
slowing cyber security is not in so
cyber security is getting more and more
uh important uh the Cyber landscape is
getting threat landscape is getting more
and more dangerous and organizations are
getting more and more aware of cyber
threats and and need for defense against
cyber threat so I think this is going to
go on for for a while until all
organizations get to a level of maturity
of cyber security
where they can start then you know start
doing incremental uh maintenance type of
investment but
uh it is likely that that is not coming
very soon
I mean we
we lulled into a sense of security in
our personal lives when we see that
Microsoft Windows comes with Windows
Defender or you download something like
uh spursky or Norton and you think
everything is fine but
all of these are things are kind of uh
a false sense of security in a certain
sense right
yeah so security cannot be done just by
uh in one thing right so uh Microsoft
defender or um uh you know McAfee uh
antivirus or Norton Antivirus Etc are
are good things uh but they do not give
you full protection because uh they can
only protect you against the kind of uh
virus malware Etc that have they have
seen But there are things like uh new
types of attacks what we call zero day
attacks that can happen and they can
easily bypass uh this kind of uh you
know protection so so you have to do
protection at multiple different levels
so what we call defense in that so so I
think that uh you know nobody should be
you know feeling comfortable with their
cyber security everybody is vulnerable
yeah we have a number of questions
coming in the chat and I'd like to
remind people to put those in the Q a so
we can find them toward the end of the
seminar for the Q a section but I also
want to let everybody know we are
recording this and we'll be sending out
an email with a link to this recording
um so
please you know be confident you can
review them at the
discussion we're having
so
just to read it to reiterate it's a
vital function but
there's
really a a whole lot of vulnerability
that's
out there it's something where as well
understood as cyber security is
um there's still so many more risks
coming out at us from every different
direction can you comment on on this
finding where half of the the CIA cisos
and cios of
like 2021 basically said they're not
ready
yeah so actually kovid uh and we locked
down and uh restrictions on movements
Etc moved uh people uh from offices to
working from home and that means remote
login into the uh network uh and servers
that were supposed to be actually under
uh strong security with the firewalls
and and intuition detection system Etc
but now that everybody in the
organization or almost everybody in the
organization is connecting to the
network through uh various kinds of
remote logging mechanism uh it basically
exposes the organization uh because it
extends the perimeter of the
organization uh to uh sort of unknown uh
perimeter
yeah so the other issue is that
maintaining
servers for running running various
kinds of services uh within premises has
kind of become expensive uh difficult to
maintain and also requires continuous
upgrade so therefore people are now
moving into Envy because the internet
speed has increased quite a bit so
people like to go uh to run their
services on the cloud which is hosted
somewhere else which is not hosted
within the premises of the organization
so because of these uh and because of
increased digitalization uh it is very
difficult now to actually uh do security
of the organization just by doing
perimeter security as it used to be uh
some time ago uh and this must be uh
concerning the csos Chief Information
Security offices and they are actually
they have to continuously evaluate the
Cyber risk of the organization because
that basically uh means uh on
continuously updating the the resilience
uh the the state of resilience of the
organization so so therefore I it's not
uh um it's not surprising that most uh
cto's and CIO the cios are worried that
they are still not fully secure
growth in
positions available that this highlights
the fact that
there's uh according to the the U.S
National Institute of Standards and
Technology
standards body in the U.S looks at these
things and they found that there's about
a million positions of cyber Security
Professionals but half of them are not
filled and then the cyber security
Ventures looked at worldwide 3.5 million
unfilled cyber security positions by
2025.
um
these are kind of Staggering numbers but
based on what you've said in the scope
of the threat
this seem at all unreasonable
he has a situation in India it is even
worse because we do not have as many
skilled uh cyber Security Professionals
as uh we need and also the need uh the
demand is increasing because people as I
as I said before as people are kind of
waking up to the uh potential of uh
cyber threats and they are realizing
that they need to actually have cyber
Security Professionals uh working uh you
know 24 7 to actually protect their
network servers and Cloud infrastructure
Etc so so this number is actually are at
least unfulfilled jobs uh situation in
India is probably worse in at least in
the US it's showing about 50 percent in
India it is probably uh even uh less
than 50 percent
fascinating and the the number of
different roles that have to be filled
is
is kind of Staggering you've got you
know the red team and blue team for
people who are dealing with uh sort of
gaming out the scenarios of attacks and
defenses and you have uh analysts you
have people who are architects of the
the overall security structure
um these are all
different ways that people can go once
they enter the industry yes
yeah so it's a service cyber security
um has multiple different sites like
offensive versus defensive so cyber
attackers they are also cyber Security
Experts they know where the
vulnerabilities are they try to they
know how to find the vulnerabilities in
a running system and they try to
actually uh use the exploit that but on
the other hand uh if you want uh to
disarm the Cyber attackers you have to
actually be one step ahead of them and
you have to create your own red team
which would be attacking your
infrastructure all the time and then
actually figure out uh where where where
the weaknesses are what are the
vulnerabilities and so on and then they
can actually uh you can then plug those
holes so so red teaming is one such
thing blue teamers actually do the
opposite they actually try to protect
the system when rate team is in action
so that they can know what is the what
is the strength of their current defense
and if they find because the red team
can overpower The Blue Team then that
means that their organization needs
um further defense mechanism and defense
uh you know infrastructure so so that's
uh that's uh part of you know uh kind of
jobs that cyber Security Professionals
do but then other jobs in cyber security
are basically uh you know application
security analysis like you know when
when you are developing software
figuring out how to make it secure how
to how to uh test it for security and
how to actually patch the problem with
respect to security malware analysis
which allows you to actually uh you know
pull apart a malware and figure out how
this malware works and and then figure
out how to mitigate against such malware
attacks
um there are Network Security
Consultants there are uh Operation
Center analysts so there are various
different roles that come up
uh you know if you look at the job
descriptions of cyber security job
hotels you will see all these different
kinds of roles that they are advertising
for
yeah we did have a question in the chat
about which role is the best for the
future in cyber security is there such a
thing or are all of these different
roles
it depends on uh what you like what what
what uh What uh your uh Acumen is in
like for example uh if you want to be a
red team or you have to have an
offensive mind you have to have a mind
to get into the issues of an offense uh
you know of a cyber hacker now that may
not be some everybody's thing so they
might actually not do like red teaming
or vapt or vulnerability assessment
penetration testing or threat hunting
rather they might do malware analysis or
they might do uh cyber security software
development or on network security
Consulting so so I think that I wouldn't
say what is best in in an absolute uh
way uh it's best to actually figure out
uh by actually getting into the field
and learning and then see what you like
and what you want where your uh you know
main skills uh are uh you know your
mentality and skills uh has to align
otherwise you know you will be not very
good at the job you might be able to do
some of the job but to be very good at
the job you have to make sure that uh
the thing that you are learning is very
interesting to you uh it it actually
excites you and it actually you can
think about it as as something that you
would do uh you know day in and day out
and and and that is something that you
have to figure out uh based on uh you
know your exposure
to the topics yeah and you really
organizations rely on having
you know a fairly complete set of all
these different roles in order to be
able to to create a complete cyber
security uh so it's it's not a matter of
which one is best but all you know which
one you're best at
um that'll make you uh a higher demanded
person
um to
what do you think about these salary
scales we pulled these off of the
Glassdoor Indio website for different
roles if you start off as a cyber
security engineer and then build your
career to the level of cyber security
architect and then ciso but are these uh
realistic kind of salary ranges from
what you've seen
uh it's on the on the conservative side
as I see it like for example I I think
40 lakh you know I'm assuming this is a
annual salary so foreign
not necessarily to a full-fledged
engineer
um I would say uh it would be between 7
to 12 lakhs if you if you have a
specialization in cyber security you
should get uh between seven to uh 12
lakhs to start with uh if you're if
you're a trainee you might get something
like 4 lakhs to seven lakhs in terms of
Architects I think seven lakhs is a
little too uh uh low uh probably between
20 and 42 would be more
um natural for medium-sized companies
for large size Banks Etc it could be you
know double that or triple that but but
to get to that point you know you have
to invest many years of service in cyber
security you know you don't get this
kind of salary right away after taking a
course or or doing a big Tech in cyber
security things like that it takes time
it takes investment of a career to
actually get to the point where you will
become a cyber security architect uh and
or a CSO right so it's a chief
information security officer so yeah so
I can I think that the the higher end of
this salary is uh more sensible the
lower end seems a little too low uh but
you know it's possible that in a very
small company that's the kind of salary
they can afford to pay for those roles
and as you said it if you're starting
out you might look at the lower end but
you would probably want to accelerate as
you gain skills as you gain experience
and as you gain reputation
um there's a lot of different skills
that you need in order to be able to
build out that kind of cyber security
career that might lead
to the more advanced
roles can you comment on on some of
these and how important they are for
somebody to be aware of
yeah so normally if you are if you're
going to be in cyber security even if
you're a red teamer or blue teamer or or
the threat analyst or or Malvern list or
whatever you have to know overall about
cyber security what are the different
aspects of cyber security like every uh
system that you actually encounter has a
network either wireless network or
Wildlife network or something and and
those things uh actually have lots of
weaknesses like so wireless networks
have a lot of weaknesses and we have to
figure out how to secure the
communication so network security then
vulnerability assessment even if you are
not becoming a vulnerability assessment
engineer you actually have to know how
to do it and what what it is about a
risk assessment risk management or how
to do threat analysis like you know in
order to do a risk assessment you have
to know uh threat analysis what are the
threats to my system how to analyze that
in terms of by looking at how the data
flows through the system what are the
different
components of the system and how they
are connected to each other based on
that you can probably uh you know you
can do threat analysis uh you have to
think about resilience or business
continues you have to think about uh you
know protecting the data especially
customer data or personally identifiable
information data
uh digital forensics is when after and
after you get an attack you want to
analyze the system you want to analyze
the memory footprint you want to analyze
the network logs Etc to know how it
happened and why it happened and and
based on that in you know in order for
the future you want to make better
defenses uh so Incident Management when
an attack happens how do you go about
managing uh you know so that the attack
does not completely devastate the system
uh asset and inventory management is
about you know knowing all your not only
all your Hardware but also all your
network components all your software
applications Etc
uh data privacy data management identity
management is very important for
authorization and authentication so
these are all things that you uh you
need to know
to actually you know even to get started
on cyber security because you know at
least you need to know what these are
and why uh we need to uh know uh about
them uh now if you want to become an
expert in some something you you you
then have to drill down into that like
if you want to become a straight analyst
or risk assessment engineer or
vulnerability assessment engineer or
network security engineer you have
different parts today but but you have
to know more or less you know the
breadth breadth of all this Concepts and
and what they are and how they connect
to each other
you also have to be able to use the
various tools and
this is just a kind of a sampling but
you need to be familiar with the
colleague Linux environment you need to
be able to use different tools for a
penetration testing for
um
analysis or figuring out or capturing
Network packets so these are
capturing the web traffic so these are
all different tools that are covered in
the rate streaming course uh but you
know for other things in cyber security
there are other tools but these are
mostly you know tools that are essential
for HTML
yeah and
so it's important to gain experience in
in using them Hands-On
as you'll you'll be asked questions if
you interview for a role
about how you've used these tools and
maybe even challenge to give examples so
um
let's ask another poll question and we
know that everyone is here because
you're interested in this career area
so what has stopped you up till now for
those of you who aren't already enrolled
in a program of this type or enrolled
with simply learning because I know some
of you are and we're very grateful for
that but um
if
you're you haven't taken that step yet
what has stopped you what do you looked
for that you haven't found in a program
put more than one answer in here I'm
going to leave this open for another 10
seconds
let's finish
here we go ending the poll
the two biggest concerns are finding a
program that is complete
comprehensive covers all the skills that
we just talked about and then finding a
program that gives you practical
examples practical exposure use the
tools and examples you can show
of work you've done in the program
to show that you're capable
so
Professor if we can talk about the
Excuse me while I adjust my systems here
so the program that you the IIT Comfort
offers along with the simple Learners
the delivery partner is the professional
certification program in cyber security
red team for ethical hacking and
penetration
so can you
um
the four things we talked about what how
does it meet those requirements
uh so so this uh course is actually for
so in cyber security is a pretty vast
subject so we we could actually uh
create a certification program in cyber
defense but uh that might be that maybe
we'll do it in in future but right now
what we have offering is a uh you know
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing course uh which is basically
what you need to do with rate gaming so
you will learn about uh you know
penetration testing you will learn about
vulnerability assessment you will learn
about uh you know how to use various
tools like Canon Linux and and
Metasploit box with uh Etc to actually
um attack systems life systems to
actually figure out what where their
weaknesses are and then figuring out uh
you know helping the organization to
plug those moves so so that that's the
goal so so this
certification program is specifically
designed for rate theming role people
who want to get into red teaming kind of
uh profile uh it is not meant for blue
team profiles or it is not meant for
let's say risk assessment risk
management profile it is specifically
meant for a red teaming profile
so it's a particular way into the cyber
security field yeah
for the program you need to have a basic
understanding of programming and cyber
security so uh the bachelor's degree
you restrict this program to people who
have bachelor's degrees or are about to
receive them yes
and and you're looking for people
who have a bachelor's degree in the
technology related field so that's uh
it's not it's not really designed for
people coming in from a liberal arts
background or that type of thing right
so you have to have some programming
background and some basic understanding
of what cyber security is all about uh
if you do not know anything about cyber
security this might not be the program
uh this there may be other programs I'm
pretty sure simply learn has other
programs in cyber security uh which is
more uh coverage breadth voice coverage
this is a more in-depth course so uh so
therefore we require that the students
here have some programming experience
and some understanding of what cyber
security is all about even if they are
not in space
yep
um
we say that it doesn't require work
experience it's is it helpful to have
some work experience under your belt
in any course like this uh maturity is
very important because see in in people
who are in college uh they are actually
uh colleges often taken as kind of an
obligatory thing right so so you
actually uh try to uh you know take
shortcuts to actually fulfill the
minimum requirements to finish college
because it's it's a it's a bit more
obligatory now this kind of course
professional courses are actually not
obligatory you are taking it voluntarily
or paying money for it so therefore you
have to take it very maturely and and
actually make time uh make sure that you
do more than what is actually covered in
the lectures uh by actually getting cues
from the lectures and and and doing your
own research and doing your own
exercises that are beyond what is being
demanded in the class so that maturity
will come from
um you know a work experience and
knowing the market and and uh you know
that kind of stuff so so I think it is
uh it is helpful if you have work
experience but doesn't mean that you
cannot get maturity otherwise also so
you can be a very mature person thank
you
um and the the course is delivered fully
online
um as you said there's live lectures
and between that you have the ability to
do your
exercises Labs on the
same online environment so you log into
one place and you can get your lectures
you can do your labs and exercises and
projects can you take us through the
steps after the the first orientation
session that helps people understand
what the platform looks like and what to
expect
yeah so the orientation station is about
the platform and how how to use this
system and all that stuff so the course
is divided into basically uh four
different parts over the six months so
first you learn about ethical hacking
and and some hacking techniques and so
on uh then you are then you actually go
into vulnerability assessment where you
actually figure out learn some tools and
techniques for assisting vulnerabilities
of uh network interfaces uh operating
system applications and so on and then
you go into penetration testing where
you learn about Metasploit and other
tools to actually do penetration testing
um you know to actually you know attack
systems and and
exploit them and and prove to the uh
developers or or the organization that
the system is still not fully uh secure
or not highly secure uh so penetration
testing is the last part and then uh
there is a Capstone project that
basically uh
um supposed to utilize all the things
that you learn in this course uh and and
hopefully that caption project will give
you a scene about how uh you know like
the job of a cyber security Redeemer
um
we also have the electives which are
included in the cost of the course uh as
the name implies you don't have to take
those but they're lectures from
Professor Shukla and other folks from
IIT conport who will add you know
insights from what's happening in cyber
security
dance topics so it's always a valuable
addition to the program
good
um so these are some of the kinds of
projects you'll be asked to work on
um
like
do an attempt to
hack a victim's machine and get into the
uh
to that environment you might look at
penetration testing for a bank you might
do a vulnerability assessment so looking
at creating a report on vulnerability
and suggestions for improvement
these are all
kinds of projects that you do along the
way in the program correct
yeah I mean yeah so these are standard
uh you know uh ways of uh training uh
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testers uh uh or rate tumors to actually
create a smok system uh which is very
similar to a real uh system uh that is
used in Banks and or other places and
then ask them to actually hack it uh and
uh more uh they can act uh better points
they get and therefore they can prove
their abilities to plan and attack and
exploit and you use the right set of
tools that we have learned in course
like this
culminates in the Capstone project so
you might pick a project of one of those
types or something similar and
you get to pick as the learner what you
want to work on and then you spend
several weeks working under the
direction of one of your instructors
to create your solution create your
answer to that challenge right
yeah yeah so Capstone project is very
important part of this kind of
certification course because uh you know
you learn various parts of the course
and you do uh lab exercises in various
parts of the course but to bring to bear
uh all the things that you have learned
into a real project is where you
actually uh you know learn the best
yeah and that gives you also an artifact
where your portfolio that says this is
the challenge I picked and this is how I
solved it and it's an independent
project so when you say you solved it it
means you solved it and not something
that the class together all did as a
class project
um the simply learned part of this
program offers you a community of
support so we have a program manager who
works with the
Mr Shukla and the other folks at IIT
confer to make sure that we're
delivering the program to their standard
when you join the program you join as
part of a cohort so you'll be going
through the program with a set of people
that started on the same date and we
assign a manager that helps
ensure success for the whole cohort the
instructors of course help you get
through each of the modules within the
program
you also have the support of your fellow
Learners have a community feature that
allows you to ask people questions
um
post those on a bulletin board and then
receive answers
so you don't have to just rely on what
happens in class or just your professors
and then the curriculum and the
resources are all designed to maximize
your success so it's kind of a
an ecosystem of support around you
just to mention the learning management
system
you have the ability on the same
interface to manage your curriculum to
see all the courses that are coming up
um see where you are in them
you take your live of virtual classes
and to do your labs and projects in the
sandboxed environment so you don't have
to buy or download a separate
environment for doing your homework
um you get access to Virtual machines
that allow you to do the
work and exercises some of which you go
through with the instructor during the
class and some of which you do
independently
um the
platform does tests and assessments to
to
monitor your progress and move you on
CE you're ready for the next module
the Capstone project of course as we
mentioned and system monitors your
progress prompts you for keeping up with
your peers unlocks your certificates for
each of the modules in the course as
well as the overall final certificate
from IIT comcor and it provides the
support tools we talked about including
a 24x7 help desk
and a social environment for Mutual
support
so you're never alone and you're never
out of touch with
someone who can help you we also provide
job assist services
part of the program so
um this gives you six months of
additional Services after the program
that allow you to um get access to an
exclusive job portal get resume review
and rewrite services and interview
preparation services so
this is a valuable part of the services
to help you find a job although it's not
a internship or job placement service it
is a valuable set of tools that will
help you
improve your job search and maximize
your chance of finding that next job
that's provided
by simply learn in its partner IAM jobs
so based on what
uh Professor Shukla and I have shared
with you so far
are you interested in enrolling in this
program
I'll leave this open for about 15
seconds
I'm going to close this in three two one
ninety percent of respondents said they
are interested which is fantastic
I'm going to share with you the steps
for getting enrolled
again
the process is very straightforward you
submit an application by email to ask us
at simplylearn.net
and uh
that puts you in touch with our learning
Consultants who will ask you questions
ask for
documentation of your
education work history anything else you
want to be considered
again work history is not mandatory but
the education level is so they'll ask
you to document your bachelor's degree
and they'll ask certain questions about
your aptitude for programming and cyber
security technology so once they've made
that evaluation if you qualify they'll
send you an admission offer
and
the next cohort actually starts in
September but you can take the induction
as early as next week
and that'll get you oriented and ready
for the classes to start
um
the cost of the program is one lock
sixty four thousand nine hundred ninety
nine
uh rupee
that's inclusive of tax
Emi financing is available at 56.15
5615 rupee a month
and so to get in touch with us you would
reach out to us and ask us at
simplylearn.net I did put that into the
chat so you can find it and
um there will also be a bonus offer so I
need to mention that if you reach out to
us and ask us at simplylearn.net to
enroll in the September cohort they will
share with you a discount offer that
we're
making available
and you want to ask them what the amount
of that discount is so
that's our
gift to you or be here at this webinar
so that leads to another question if you
are interested
are you interested in the September
cohort or are you looking further down
the road
I'll leave this open again for 15
seconds or so
the numbers are still changing
and I'll close this
in five four three
two one
so about a third uh well about a fifth
of our audience are interested in the
next cohort
um other third are interested in cohort
maybe right after that so about half of
the audience
total looking to get started fairly soon
if you're looking further down the road
please contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and we'll make sure that
we keep you in touch with future cohorts
as they're announced as well as
answering any other questions you have
and
at this point I'd like to go on into the
Q a
hold on a second
apologize for
turning away but
making sure I've got the other system
where I've set up the presentation
um
so at this point we can
go on to the Q a I'm going to stop
sharing this slide because
I don't want to talk to the slide you
want to talk to the professor and the Q
a has quite a number of uh questions in
it so
um
somebody asked how can I become an
expert in hacking because it seems that
I'm having a lot of issues and errors
while I'm doing this so uh with this
course help someone like that professor
uh let's hope so I mean I I'm not sure
what kind of uh
hacking the the person is trying to do
and where he's getting the know-how and
why he's getting so many errors so it's
difficult to say but uh hopefully
um a course like this where they
introduce him or her to the right set of
tools right set of techniques and write
what process by which to actually plan
and hack and exploit here we had a
question out of the chat um what's the
reason that cyber criminals are
attracted towards informal sectors of
less than formal sectors
I I don't know if that that is
statistically proven but I can imagine
that uh formal sector has better uh
cyber security they have regulations
that they have to follow and in cyber
security so they have to have proper
cyber defense mechanism they have to
have cyber security team and ciso Etc
whereas in informal sector that may not
be the case and therefore they are less
protected so and and easier to exploit
but that is just a speculation uh I do
not know it for a fact that informal
sector attracts more cyber criminals but
it might be true
uh pardon me does this program
uh help people get certain prepare for
certification exams relevant to this
area
well uh the program the certification
exam that would be most relevant after
doing this course is ceh the certified
ethical hacker uh and probably uh it
will prepare you a long way to oscp uh
but uh not all certificates but
certainly uh CH would be uh one that
that you certainly be very much uh ahead
uh and maybe a waste it to some extent
um
somebody asked a question they have
their B Tech and CSE cyber security
um they're interested in the course but
they're also
curious to know if they can work while
they're doing the course if they can be
employed in their career while they're
doing the course
so this kind of professional
certification courses meant for people
who are working
so that's why it's mostly live lectures
are on the weekends and uh you know you
had the entire week to do your lab
exercises and you have 24x7 access to
the online labs and so on so it is meant
for people who are working
and
um it's a we ask a dedication of about
10 hours a week over the period of the
six months so it's something that uh
it's not necessarily uh
entirely
um
easy but it's something that you can
certainly do it requires commitment
um
should I do a specialization in cyber
security or Ai and ml if I'm looking for
a better career is can you make a
give advice on that
well that again you know I I mentioned
before that you have to have Acumen in
cyber security to do cyber security you
cannot if you do not have the right set
of uh uh you know skill mindset right
interest
curiosity uh you you cannot do cyber
security
uh but again for to do AIML successfully
also you have to have certain types of
equipment so I I cannot tell you know
from from sitting here you know what
will give you better career uh both have
lots of opportunities today but you have
to figure out what is the best you know
match for your cumin and your interest
and and your uh
um you know
sense senses
that you have to figure out yeah
some people
are more excited by the the challenge of
uh doing penetration testing on systems
and some people are more excited about
making systems behave in intelligent
ways and it's not really a matter of
which is better but which is better for
you
um
looking through the questions here
so can you comment on operating systems
that are used in this in this course and
uh
which operating systems are
uh but you know you can use any
operating system uh if you install the
tools uh the right set of tools in that
operating system but Kali Linux is a is
a version of Linux that comes with
already pre-installed set of tools for
hacking
for penetration testing so Kali Linux is
certainly uh What uh we prescribe for
people who are who are doing penetration
testing because it has the Indian tools
but
you can have other operating system
where you install your tools in yourself
and and use it
I have a question that somebody was
asking for advice on how to um
protect personal data on their personal
device
what are some of the things that people
should be doing
well first of all have
um strong password
if you are using Windows 11 or some
thing you use the
BitLocker you know to have the special
personally
identifying information
Etc critical information in encrypted
form
stored them in encrypted form so that
even if your system gets hacked the the
the data is no of no use to the hackers
if your data is on the cloud or data is
on a server then you should actually
have multi-factor authentication for uh
protecting protection and also you must
patch your operating system your
applications your VPN and and various
things software to actually ensure
ensure that you have up-to-date uh
all the security holes have been plugged
uh now having said that doesn't mean
mean that there is that there is never
100 guarantee uh of of security so uh so
therefore uh there may be a bug that has
not been yet discovered by the uh vendor
of the software but uh discovered by the
haters and they it can exploit it these
are called zero day bugs at zero day
exploits so so things can still go wrong
but you have to do the due diligence
um to reduce the possibility so it's a
it's a matter of probability so you have
to increase the pro or decrease the
probability of being attacked but you
cannot really get to zero probability
but you can go uh pretty low
I have a question from somebody who has
a legal background what would somebody
have to have
uh from a legal background
um what additional skills or
capabilities should they have in order
to succeed
cyber security as well
uh well there there are Professionals in
Cyber Law and cyber policy Etc but at
least you know you know you you have to
understand uh cyber security why where
what are the threats what are the
vulnerabilities why cyber attacks happen
who are the possible cyber attacks what
are the attack vectors uh what are the
different attack Parts uh how the uh you
know attacks uh you know uh stopped by
cyber uh protection tools how the
detection happens how authentication and
authorization happens uh you have to
understand the uh you know little bit
about uh
Computing and operating system and
application and vulnerabilities where
they come from uh yeah so so it's a
whole lot of work if you if you're not
exposed to uh computers
um in the sense of programming Etc
Network
understanding the network Etc
um it's a tall order it's not impossible
but it's a taller
that answers that question
um somebody who's in the background of
devops and wants to move into cyber
security
um
and
is there is this a good path for them to
move in through this aspect of of cyber
security
um are there other
paths that they might call
yeah so Dave stick-offs that that is uh
being secure uh you know where devops is
is combined with security as a as a
continuous process uh one can actually
uh you know integrate penetration
testing uh of the software as they are
as they are you know being developed so
it is possible
uh to actually have this skill and and
be uh part of devsecops uh but uh you
know you do not have to necessarily do
penetration testing uh uh you know as as
part of devsecops vulnerability
assessment yes it's it's a part of Dev
stick Ops uh but but here we are
thinking more in terms of red teaming
rather than you know using your
vulnerable assessment skill in devsecops
in this course but it is possible okay I
want to answer a question that's come
from several people this is uh we do
offer the job assist services but not
job placement so
um this is not a job guarantee program
or that type of thing but we do offer
help in finding that next job
um
penetration testing that we're talking
about in this course is web penetration
testing or does it
Embrace or Encompass other aspects of
penetration testing
you know it covers a lot of gift
medication testing so web validation
application penetration testing desktop
applications or or server applications
penetration testing Network manipulation
testing so uh operating system testing
so there's several things
okay
um
if somebody has 10 years of experience
in database skills is this a potential
career pivot for them
yeah so so I assume that when when they
say 10 years of experience in database
they actually uh actually do uh
programming uh write queries for the
database or do uh maintain database or
you know optimize database and plan uh
you know uh the uh database tables and
all that stuff so so that basically
means that they have programming skills
uh they have understanding of uh
computer uh systems uh so I think that
this is uh you know that's kind of like
the prequisite for this course
now having said that uh as I always say
that uh no program can make you uh
successful unless you uh really put in
the effort to one and want to succeed so
uh you have to really put in the effort
to do the course well uh to understand
everything to do the projects and lab
work properly and go out of the way to
do additional uh studies and additional
uh lookup of Concepts and and
techniques and tools
um so that you you become uh you know
very very
comfortable with the subject so so that
is required uh even after you have the
database or other types of past
experience
okay
um
question about what's the difference
between hacking in general and ethical
hacking what makes it hacking ethical
hacking
yeah so so hacking uh you know there are
hackers uh which we call black hat
hackers they actually are the people who
actually find vulnerabilities file find
problems uh in your in your systems or
your software or your network but they
don't tell you they actually exploit it
attack you
um it's filtered your data uh or disrupt
your system or or exact Financial loss
um Etc uh so these are people we call
black hat hackers or or harmful hackers
or they are actually uh you know
considered criminals uh why can't
hackers are hackers who are ethical
hackers who actually uh do not hack into
your system unless you ask them to and
once they hack into your system uh once
they find the weaknesses and problems
they actually immediately inform you or
what is called a responsible disclosure
so when they disclose it to you then you
can fix them and you may reward them or
whatever you know depending on your box
Bounty program so so these are white hat
hackers so ethical hackers are actually
uh they are uh kind of bound by uh you
know an ethical uh oath um not
necessarily a formal oath or something
but they are bound by the idea of doing
things synthetically and responsibly uh
whereas hacking in general may include
uh other kinds of hackers who are not
bound by any ethical uh standards
and what are some of the jobs and
government sectors in this field can you
comment on that
yeah so government sector is not
different from other sectors uh like a
government is running a lot of
e-governance uh e-governance Services
um like in India for example we have uh
e-passport we have uh e-visa we have
um aadhar which is the identity system
we have uh banking uh you know and
various other systems which are enabled
through this what you call India stack
so these things are continuously getting
attempt and government needs a lot of
people to protect them
uh but in general what we see in the at
least in India is that the government
tend to not hire cyber Security
Professionals directly they tend to use
other consulting firms uh lots lots
consulting firms for cyber security so
uh there may not be always government
jobs uh for doing these things there may
be some but not necessarily a lot so you
might work for the government
organizations protecting government
organizations through a consulting
company which more likely
it's an interesting Insight that the
government would use third parties more
than own employees so
and
I'm not I'm wondering if that changes at
different levels of government or
different uh
one of the reason is that it's uh the
government salaries are at certain fixed
levels right and cyber expert salaries
so government salaries will not be able
to attract the uh you know High skill
cyber experts but they may be available
through Consulting Engineers that makes
sense
um so I've put into the chat just now
um the link to our course page
and to the uh ask us at simplylearn.net
email it's all the time we have for
questions we had so many more questions
than we could get to I apologize to the
people that we couldn't address but we
are at time so
at this point I just want to say thank
you to
Professor Shukla
thank you
and I want to thank him for his time his
knowledge and
his expertise in sharing that with us
and
go ahead and give the
final thank you to our audience as well
we want to thank everyone who joined us
this evening
um we appreciate your taking the time to
be with us
and we hope that we can welcome you into
the Learning Community with IIT conport
and simply learn you can use the QR code
that will take you to our webpage or
look at the link that I put into the
chat
and we hope to see you
if not in our September cohort then
maybe in one of the cohorts down the
road so thanks again for being here and
that concludes our webinar
thank you thank you Stuart
okay